thank you mr chairman
everything cost too damn much first it
was the pandemic's fault now it's big
meat that's why i said big meat who knew
biden's white house blaming the soaring
cost of meat on the greed of producers
hold that thought as the administration
presides over an inflation-bloated
economy not seen in 40 years
the president the secretary of
agriculture have both spoken to what
we've seen as the greed of meat
conglomerates that is an area where
people go to the grocery store and
they're trying to buy a pound of meat
two pounds of meat 10 pounds of meat
it is the prices are higher that is in
his view
and the view of our secretary of
agriculture because of you could call it
corporate greed short
corporate greed and big meat
blaming bid me and instead republican
senator tom cotton says they should be
blaming their own policies
they're blaming everyone for this record
inflation when it just goes back to
democratic policies look we've had this
pandemic for two years first it was oil
and gas companies now it's meat
conglomerates maybe next week it's going
to be the elf on the shelf when there
aren't enough christmas presents under
the tree
so who is your your boogeyman when
you're running successfully for d.a
how did you portray the democratic rival
i always portrayed the rival as someone
who was soft on crime but you know it
really wasn't about them no it really
was about light it was about how strong
i was my record what i did i didn't
really spend a lot of time trashing and
yeah politics aren't that now it's not
emphasizing that's possible to be
emphasizing the
negative but can i talk about this go
ahead
i was like i should have studied janet's
career
here's the bottom line they're always
looking for an excuse
he doesn't want to admit that it's him
that it's his policies
that's buck that's politics
that's not politics you always blame the
other guy no no no no we've got 3 500
that the average american family has to
pay this year just to survive compared
to last year last year was a really bad
year you know the pandemic and
everything else hit but with joe biden
in there he keeps putting money into the
stimulus into the you know
infrastructure this and that and the
other thing his so-called biden uh
bipartisan infrastructure and the bottom
line is that with inflation that's the
highest has been in 40 years and we're
at what is it 6.9
you know and he keeps wanting to pour
more money in and that means your
money's worth less because there's a lot
more of it but i want to stick with
political stereotyping dana and
the reagan administration remember
welfare queens he portrayed a whole
class of people who became the enemy of
republican voters in a in a very
succinct way by focusing on one
purported welfare queen and they didn't
story didn't even pan out but it was
very effective politically that's what
you do to your rival don't you define
your rival in the in this case big meat
big meat is something people can
remember but they're making up a rival
right so like big meat is not their
rival right the big the rival is
there are the republicans but it's also
the fact just that they have 69 of
people in the abc poll saying that they
are disapproved of the way the bidet
administration is handling inflation
that's a huge wake-up call what else can
you get 69 of americans to agree on
today they agree on that so what
happened so a progressive group puts out
a
poll tested messaging and says here's
what you do to fight back you just blame
all of the private sector for being
greedy and they've tried it with the
energy companies now they're trying it
with me now i'm not saying that there
isn't a problem especially when it comes
to the um producers like the cattle
ranchers
that is a problem i do think and that's
one of the things that the um both the
trump administration and the butt
administration are looking into but when
it comes to consumer prices all these
other things fall into it you got to get
the cows to market you got to get the
trucks fueled you got all of that stuff
adds up packaging is more expensive the
supply chain all that happens um but if
you ever wondered how the democrats all
get up on get on one
page on the same page and they're all
singing from the same song sheet it's
because you have a poll tested thing
that goes out and says greed that's it
let's talk about greed every morning
today's headlines my last thing is that
the problem is initially they said
inflation wasn't happening then they
said it's transitory slash temporary
then they're saying well it's going to
get better right after the first of the
year now they're saying actually
it's the greedy meat packers you know
it's so funny how the issue has to hit
exactly right
for it for it to be the economy so it
has to be the economy at that moment i
mean for it to be the pandemic whatever
it has to be
and it just seems it's such a roll of
the dice to the last day of the election
do you politicians ever take
responsibility no if you're good one i
like
you did but you're a judge judge and if
you're a politician
okay true well you know what you're
perfect
yeah that makes you feel better
the perfect couple um so not a couple
okay
dana said something and she's right the
guy at the supermarket geraldo with the
little gun the price gun he shoots it on
the meat there he gets a note from big
meat every week what the price of the
steak is going to be what do you think
that price comes from you got increased
transportation costs labor costs
packaging costs fuel costs energy costs
it's all expensive so big meats carrying
a lot of cost so they're going to raise
prices you don't get to become big meat
by selling meat for free geraldo i get
that if you sell meat for free you
become little meat and you don't want to
belittle me do you have that that graph
that funky graph on how the price of gas
has uh has really plummeted uh
it looks like there's been a dramatic
drop in the price of gasoline right but
as my young colleague points out that's
only 10 cents they've they've squashed
the vertical to make that graph look
like the price
plummeting yeah it's a slick sale did
you learn a little something i already
knew it but now the audience knows how
slick the democrats are yeah it went
down 10 cents in two weeks so although
is that because big oil is less greedy
no
because omicron has all the oil traders
i don't like the idea that that john
dutton from yellowstone is raising
prices like that doesn't fit in my head
yeah it just doesn't matter i have not
seen yellowstone but i would say this
meat is not even the biggest problem it
looks like used cars is up 31 yeah
58 meat is at 13 right uh then you got
furniture followed right behind that
jewelry electricity they say that they
affect everybody as you mentioned before
3 500 per family i get it so what you do
is you don't have to have all the
answers but you have to try and the
minute i think you just diminish your
argument when you set up somebody as the
fall guy in this case it's a
corporation's big meet then we've had
corporations big oil and
you don't have to create an enemy the
other thing is in no offense but the
press secretary should not be answering
complex economic problems have the
treasury secretary out there that's the
labor secretary can i tell you something
you don't get big meat statements that
people mock for 24 hours i would like to
have an expert that knows more than the
reporters out in front so why not let me
tell you what happens when the economy
is good and you have good news you can
find anybody from the treasury
department and do the briefing as soon
as it's tough they're busy they can't
show up let me tell you something
happened the fall of 2008 and i was
learning what a credit default swap was
every single of that but i'm sure you
you signaled to the press corps didn't
you what the story of the day was i
remember when jimmy carter was president
and i was in uh latin america covering
his trip to uh to south america and they
somebody ran through the hallways at
four in the morning the story is amy
carter the story is amy carter so
everybody wrote about emmy carter that
day it's just the press can be easily
steered to cover the big meat and not
anymore
just you've saved me over and over it
doesn't make your meat bigger
they call me
they call me
just read
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else